♪ [intro music] ♪
Give me one minute,
and I'll show you how VPC Service Controls
can help you create a custom fence
around your cloud infrastructure.
Think of a cell in your body
that has a context-aware control center
within the nucleus
that controls what flows
in the cell membrane and what stays out.
VPC Service Controls can do the same
for your cloud projects.
They help you keep unwanted things
from passing through your membrane
so that your data isn't retrieved
from your server,
copied, or transferred
without authorization.
They also allow for a flexible variety
of project configurations,
including hybrid environments
with on-premise services,
using Private Google Access
or multiple cloud perimeters
that access each other via ingress
and egress rules
called a Secure Data Exchange.
You also get near real-time security logs
that report denials and activity
deemed potentially malicious,
as well as IP address data.
You can build that into a dashboard,
using Data Studio,
since logs go to BigQuery.
You can set up these rules,
either in your console
or via the gcloud terminal,
or via code, using the API.
There are two types
of configurations at this time.
One is called enforce mode,
which actively prevents access
to protected services.
The other is dry run mode,
which log violations
but does not prevent them from occurring.
There's no additional charge
for using VPC Service Controls.
Common use cases are monitoring threats,
transferring data from another cloud,
or to set up a Private Access
to Google APIs and services
within your projects.
So, next time you're looking to manage
your network and security perimeters
to keep your data safe,
take a minute to look
at the context-aware VPC Service Controls.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/vpc-service-controls
♪ [outro music] ♪